Argentina has won the 2022 football
World Cup in Qatar the final against
defending Champions France had fans on
the edge of their seats as it went to
extra time and then a penalty shootout
the match is already being called a
classic
thousands to the capital
streets of Buenos Aires are
white and smiling faces
there was singing cheering dancing and
no shortage of Tears
I'm 41 years old and we suffered in the
1990 Championship watching this world
cup with my children it was something
wonderful
foreign
lost to West Germany in the 1990 final
the country's last World Cup win was 36
years ago that was with football legend
Diego Maradona
fantastic it's the third world cup I've
seen but it's really the first one I've
had with my daughters and we've decided
to come here because I think it's a
historic moment
the game was a nail biter until the very
end when Argentina dethroned former
Champions France in a penalty shootout
foreign
[Applause]
for many in Argentina and fans around
the world this game was about one man
Lionel Messi the 35 year old is
considered by many to be the greatest
player of all time winning almost every
trophy imaginable during his long career
now he's achieved his life goal and
produced lifelong memories for thousands
of argentinians along the way
[Music]
[Applause]
well our correspondent Nicole Reese is
in the Argentinian Capital Buenos Aires
she sent us this update on the
celebrations
they they have been Desiring to win the
World Cup for days now and now a dream
has come true for many of them they're
celebrating here and there's no getting
around it these past few hours during
the match they have gone through Joy
they've gone to through uncertainty and
until The Bitter End they were just
hanging in there until they finally won
this World Cup tonight Buenos Aires is
going to be up on its feet celebrating
and tomorrow pretty much everyone here
tells me that they're not going to uh to
work they want to continue the
celebrations they want to welcome their
team and they want to just enjoy this
moment pretty much everybody here says
this will be an Endless Summer of
celebrations and that's also the feel
here on the streets of Buenos Aires